you want to graph the cosine graph and
you learn how to do this in a previous
lesson but the way it stands right now
the inverse of this graph is not a
function and the reason that it isn't as
you can see that when you draw a
horizontal line like so its intercepting
the graph at more than one point okay so
what mathematicians decided to do is to
restrict the domain just look at a piece
of this cosine graph and they're just
looking at the part from 0 to PI so what
I did here is I darkened this portion
here so that we can see a little bit
better and now all the way it stands
when you draw a horizontal line it's
only crossing this portion of the graph
at most once so that means that the
inverse of this piece will be a function
so what we're gonna do now when you find
the inverse of a function you switch the
input in the output you switch the X and
the y values and so what we're gonna do
here is we're just going to locate these
points and we're going to interchange
the X and the y and graph those points
so this point right here is the point 0
comma 1 okay this key point right here
is PI over 2 comma 0 and then this key
point over here is PI comma negative 1
okay so what we're going to do now is
we're going to switch the X and the y
coordinates so if we do that this point
here 0 1 is now going to be 1 comma 0
right so PI over 2 is 1 point 5 7 comma
0 so when we switch that it's going to
be 0 comma 1 point 5 7 because remember
pi is 3.14 and then over here when we
switch PI a negative 1 we get negative 1
comma PI or we'll just say negative 1
comma 3.14 okay so now let's plot these
points so one zero so one would be right
about here
because this is one point five seven so
it's about two-thirds of the way comma
zero so that's going to be right there
so there's there's that point right
there now at this point here PI over 2
comma zero when we interchange those we
get zero comma one point five seven so
that's going to be 0 one point five
seven it can be right about let's see
here this make this to make this about
three so one point five seven would be
right about here okay and then this
point negative one three point one four
we're going to go left one which is
right about there
three point one four it's going to be
right up right up over here somewhere ok
so now when we graph this the graph
going to look something like this now
when you graph the inverse of a graph
what you'll notice is that it's a
reflection over the line y equals x this
45-degree line so if I sketch this in
here
okay roughly the line y equals x is
right there and you can see that this
graph we're actually like it's the
mirror image over this 45 degree line so
that's how you graph the cosine inverse
graph just remember this graph doesn't
keep going it just goes from this point
to this point and that's it because
we're just looking at that particular
portion of the cosine graph so I hope
this helped you understand how to graph
it better
subscribe to the channel check out more
math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to helping you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon